[music]
How you guys doing? I know it's late in
the day.
I know I'm the only thing standing
between you guys and a happy hour and a
black tide Versailles for some of you,
but uh let's just all hang out for a
little bit longer and let's uh let's
dream a little bit. And it's it's not
hard to dream at a facility like this
because it's just so inspiring. So many
incredible companies. Thank you for to
the Machina organizers. Just an
incredible event. I think they deserve a
round of applause. Actually, it's been
incredible. Thank you. So, my name is
Nick Radford. I'm CEO of Persona AI. And
Persona's ambition is to build the
world's toughest humanoid. Think think
environments that are outside where it's
raining. It might be cold. It might be
super hot. And we need to help
supplement and provide a labor
substitution solution for environments
where you're using tools, whether it's a
welding torch, whether it's a angle
grinder. Think like the four Ds, the
dull, the dirty, the dangerous, and yet
the declining jobs. The demographics
around this are stark. There's insane
labor shortages, replete across so many
different industries. And we feel that
one of those applicable solutions is
going to be uh embodied AI agents like
humanoids.
To me, this is one of the most exciting
moments. I've dreamt for so long about
being in an industry at the dawn of
something. I got to NASA in like 2000.
It was kind of like sort of during the
space shuttle, kind of building the
space station. And I had always just
wondered like what would it have been
like to have been part of the Apollo
program, some some new industry as it
was forming or think aviation when it
was getting off the ground or the
telecommunications world or the
internet. And it just seems like in my
career I was just like a few years
behind the big thing every single time.
So what I love about this is this moment
right now. We are absolutely at the dawn
of a completely new industry. this
embodied AI and our feeling is humanoid
labor which is going to be just so
tremendously valuable to the planet and
the planet's resources.
The auto industry gets compared to the
burgeoning humanoid industry a lot, but
it mainly gets compared from like a
market size. The humanoid market might
be something on the order of a couple
trillion dollars, kind of like the North
American automotive market, which is
about $2.2 trillion. But I've always
felt that that analogy it falls flat
because the real power of the automotive
to humanoid analogy has to do with the
fact that in the early automotive days
supply chains didn't exist. Suppliers
didn't exist. There were very few. The
competition was fierce. There in 1900
1905 every time you turn around there
was a new automotive company joining.
There were like 1,300 brands at one
point in like 1908 and that consolidated
down to that consolidated down to uh 80
and then and then obviously on down to
the big three as we know it and actually
the North American automotive market
today we have about 40 brands as it's
been uh diversified out uh but that was
not the case and so if you really want
to talk comparison of the automotive
market we have extreme competition right
now there's There's a humanoid company
popping up uh it seems like every
Thursday. There's a model training
company popping up every Wednesday. And
that is such an enormously exciting time
uh of this market. But I've got some
really bad news. [laughter]
We the industry is not going to stay
like this forever. There's going to be
consolidation. There might be mergers.
There might be failures. There might be
things that are occurring where one
company's suited to out compete the
other company. This is the wild west
right now. It's just open war
competition and I am just tremendously
overjoyed because I've always wanted
this moment. And um hopefully we rise to
the occasion.
The other part about the automotive
analogy that I think always just falls a
little flat is yes, we've got the we've
got the makers of the cars, but
underneath them is an incredible vibrant
industry that is supporting that. Toyota
today has 60,000
individual suppliers for their cars.
60,000.
And so as the humanoid market matures,
it's compelling to think about the
layers of companies and services that
are going to be built. And we need to
stop talking, we need to stop calling
these machines robots. We've been
talking about humanoid robots for a
while. We've been talking about
industrial robots for a while. And we
keep using the word robot. But I I'm
here to tell everyone these are
platforms in the truest sense. These are
going to create ancillary industries.
The car was not a car. The automotive
was not a car. It was a platform. It
created gas stations, hotels, fast food.
Like maybe that was a bad idea, but it
created things that grew up around the
car. And the humanoid is going to do
exactly the same thing. It is going to
instigate new economies. Uh
so
here's where Persona diverges from some
of the thinking uh that's in the
industry.
We feel that not every go-to market plan
is created equal. Back to the
consolidation of the automotive
industry.
There's going to be companies that uh go
out into the blue yonder and find that
possibly the market that they thought
exists doesn't exist. And so the way the
persona has been defining the market is
pulling real data from actual vacancies
of labor. The actual economics behind
that labor. How complex is the task? How
envir how predictable is the
environment? How expensive is it going
to be to develop that? We moderate that
by the purchasing power of the client
and their willingness to adopt. And we
assign a score to clients. And so I've
been very public about this, but the
home is the last place in my view that a
humanoid robot's going to be
commercialized. It's extremely chaotic.
It's low value labor. I've actually
never had any trouble hiring a cleaning
service to come to my house. They'll
show up the same day. They work very
affordably. And so the price point that
we're going to have to have humanoids at
in the home is going to have to be just
bottom basement pricing. And so the
environment, as I said, is extremely
chaotic. And so the development costs
associated with deploying a robot in
that environment are very high. So we
use this equation. We use this
dimension. We use these dimensions to
guide us on what we're doing. So,
Persona's our our ambition is to build
the largest repository of industrialized
skill for humanoids. The way we're doing
that is we're using all these incredible
NVIDIA tools that I think so many of you
are are very aware of. But I'm here to
tell you they're exquisite, right? The
Isaac lab, the Isaac Sim, the Mojoko,
the RL uh training uh that you can
perform in this the SIM to real gap for
locomotion is actually quite uh it's
quite small for locomotion.
manipulation's another another uh
another example unfortunately but this
is a you know a real physics simulation
running the real control policies on the
robot and so but what feeds all this
right so we've we're building an entire
the the entire data pyramid which again
I'm sure so many of you are focused with
this is actual data that we're taking
with partner facilities uh there's
actually a representative of the uh
state of Louisiana here which is helping
we have we were the first humanoid
company to form partnership with a state
and so they're helping subsidize the
activities into fabrication facilities
where we have cameras on workers and
collecting all that information
but we also have to collect the data at
the task level. So we're building TUMI
devices uh not a universal manipulation
interface but a tool universal
manipulation interface and so we need to
collect data right at the point of of
execution. That data then feeds the
models on the on the post-training side.
And uh we are uh the ambition is to
deploy this to thousands of workers,
collect hundreds of thousands of data,
thousands of hours of data. And we're
interested in the the the the
fabrication task, the the welding, the
grinding, the painting, assembly in in
the heavy industrial segment. And so
Persona had uh we we've been we've been
around about 18 months. So we in those
18 months we've been able to raise our
preede round. We've hired up a team.
We've went from about five to 85 people
in in about 18 months. We designed and
developed our first several generations
of humanoids. Our gen one, our gen two,
our gen 3 just went to production for uh
an appreciable quantity of them. Uh
we've hired one of the best teams in the
world in my opinion. We have developed
an appreciable uh commercial pipeline.
And what's amazing about this is the
reception that we we've received from
our industrial partners has been
tremendous and uh it feels like uh that
they're that they're coming to us
because the the constraints that they're
facing the real world constraints in
some of these markets are just it's it's
hard to describe uh how constraining
they are to production. So our Gen One,
we did this in about nine months. our
Gen two robot in the middle. Uh we built
it and and about uh about six, seven
months after we finished our Gen One and
our Gen 3 we just went to uh production
on. And so Gen One look like a Gen One
robot does. We built uh four of these.
We used all of the tools. We set up all
the entire infrastructure, the
simulation, the machine learning that
you you need to do to train the
policies. Um it is uh was working as
about as well as a Gen One could. But
what we did after that was we quickly
and expeditiously went to our Gen 2. And
so our view is we're not going to get it
right the first time. You're going to
have to take an iterative approach uh
and speed through your development. Find
find the weak points and fix them as
fast as you as fast as you can. And so
Gen 3, which is uh these are the uh the
renders for Gen 3, is already in
production and we're building many of
them. And uh the whole concept of
persona is that we are going to be able
to outfit the robot very uh distinctly
different based on the use case, the
requirement, the environmental. So we
have a common base that the robot is
built on and the outer coverings of that
robot change.
And one important aspect of that is we
were also the first humanoid company to
sign a partnership with a major clothing
brand. So Under Arour and Persona are
co-developing soft goods, padding, outer
coverings, textiles specific for
humanoid robots. Uh this is one of the
partnerships that we have at Persona
that I'm just absolutely uh compelled
and over the moon by and I think it
really highlights uh a shift in
thinking. Uh uh Under Armour in my view
is one of the most advanced companies
when it comes to textile manufacturing
uh thermal wicking material. They house
some of the highest performing athletes
in the world uh and keep them safe. And
so safety has been a huge topic here.
And we think uh we think some of that
intrinsic safety is going to start uh on
the outer coverings of the robot. So our
beach head market so persona is building
this heavy industrial humanoid. Our
beach head market is in one of the most
uh tremendous and critical industries
that we have. So we are deploying a
humanoid robot welder uh with HD
Hyundai. Uh it's it's public
information. You can find it online. And
we are delivering our first batch of
robots to them at the end of this year.
So we will have gone from inception to
shipping product in two years.
Not bad. [laughter] Thank you. So
welding is just incredible. So each one
of these ships uh a 300 to 400 meter
vessel has about 300 kilometers of
welding in it. It's just insane. So HD
produces HD Hyundai produces about 50
ships a year of this class. That's 14
million kilometers of welding. That's
like welding to the moon and back 14
times. 40 times. I don't do the math.
It's a lot. And so each worker is doing
about 5 to 10 meters of weld a day.
Okay. The problem is they are super
constrained on labor. They have
thousands of open positions for jobs
that we think these humanoids are going
to do. And so, okay, well, let's set up
the training pipeline. Let's do some
expert demonstration uh for the welding.
So, recently we deployed uh the robot,
our Gen1 system to an industrial
facility. Another little piece of advice
for for the young startup community, get
out into the market as soon as you can.
Don't wait. Don't stay too long in the
lab. go test this thing out into the
real world because I guarantee you, you
don't know everything and the only way
you're gonna learn is to get out there
and do. So, there's a company in
Houston, it's a huge fabrication
facility. We called them up and we said,
"We want to do some welding for you."
And so, to my knowledge, this is the
first humanoid robot
doing welding I've ever seen. Now, maybe
they exist. I'm not sure. I haven't seen
them, but this was a tremendous thing.
So we were teleyoperating and expertly
demonstrating to the robot uh how to
perform the weld. And so we're
collecting all that data. It's feeding
back into the uh into the into the
simulation and foundation model layers.
And uh not bad for the first time.
You're actually watching a video of us
doing this literally the first time. And
uh you can tell the team was just super
excited about it. And uh the the um it's
a little bit of comic relief here at the
end. I mean, they were kind they were
kind of tired, you know, watching the
robot do its job, but uh but so then
after you expertly demonstrate, go back.
Go back. So after you Well, that video
is not playing. Can we play the video?
That's a video. Well, that's a video of
a robot doing it uh autonomously.
And so, you know, this is just an
absolute dawn of a new age, the Wild
West. Um it's just incredible. And I
love this quote from Yates. And this is
this is uh it's okay. We can skip the
video. This to me is just speaks volumes
to our efforts. We're not going to wait
to strike while the iron's hot. We are
literally going to make the iron hot by
striking. And I think that that that
sort of that deep down ambition is is uh
is really what sets companies apart from
each other. Go fast, break things. Um,
it's been incredible and uh, thank you
for sharing some time with me.